quick thoughts on Tomb Raider what the
hell was that bike scene in the
beginning that felt like a scene from a
Disney Channel original movie it took a
long time this movie for Lara Croft to
become Laura Croft with a pretty lame
back story dad flashbacks have been
overdone before they were pretty cheesy
wasn't crazy about the dad actor and
then the ship scene in the beginning
with her out at sea and it's pouring
rain
I know it's based off the video game but
the special effects looked like it was
straight from a video game I'd rather
just watch the cutscenes from the video
game at that point no other jumps ahead
Lara Croft dude were just jumps for her
to jump or they over exaggerated her
motions and her struggles but really
there's no action to why she was doing
it her purpose for like a lot of it was
just for the trailer no Laura Croft
herself Alicia vikander loved her in ex
machina she won the Oscar for Best
Supporting Actress for the Danish girl
she was great she played the new type of
Lara Croft like from the new video games
which I loved really well or she's
strong she kicks butt but she's also
very human and Walton giggles from Vice
Principals
and hateful a it was a great villain
didn't overplay it my only problems what
they do Danny was character and they
kind of put him on his side step at a
point and then I got really weird and
then the slaves he's telling let's go
save Laura they're all like yeah let's
do it
but they show them just walking there's
no rush there's taking their time and
that's really the surface of his
character is just find her at the end
and together to the island on a ship she
felt a little wasted there and
ultimately the two meant they get to is
disappointing it felt small I felt like
I should have felt huge and looked
amazing and had waterfalls like in the
video game but did not it felt like
there's only three rooms and it could
have used a little more scares because
the scares they did have worked really
well so many people in the theater were
jumping up when the booby traps are
coming up or when that skeleton would
pop up from the casket the pacing of the
movie was really slow in the beginning
the middle really dragged where she
finds her dad the third act really
kicked up and felt enjoyable and you
cared more and I hope in the seat will
they spend more times in the tombs I let
her do her thing and it's set up great
for the sequel the ending reveal was
really good and set up a good villain
and I loved that little scene where she
gets two guns at the end I was nervous
she was gonna say no to them and stick
with the arrow but that's what I miss
the most in this she didn't get to shoot
a gun but they're saving for the sequel
wish it was in this that's gonna bring a
score down to but it wasn't terrible it
wasn't good so that's getting a 5 out of
10
comment below your quick thoughts about
this movie I respond to everybody let's
get discussion going can please
subscribe a new bunch of TV shows movie
reviews celebrity interviews you name it
till next time